in terms of my question I think most
your belief that it's extremely
important everything that we're doing to
speak our mind to speak freely that's
why we're here but in terms of
practicality there's a lot of things
that get in the way of our license
students do we have our TV a little poor
job prospector so in terms of
practicality what are kind of maybe your
tips and your perspective on the steps
that students can take to kind of speak
their mind while not sacrificing well I
can tell you a couple of things that are
very practical don't write in your
essays what you think the professor
wants to hear there's absolutely no
excuse whatsoever for doing that now
first of all most professors even those
who have descended into a state of
ideological possession let's say most of
them had still have enough character to
grade an essay that's well written
properly so you're actually taking less
of a risk than you would think by
stating what you have to stay but look
if you start practicing when you're in
university the mistakes are rather low
pandering to the audience let's say and
say what you think will get you by
you're gonna train yourself to do that
and what that means is you're gonna
train yourself in the falsification of
your character and your character is the
only thing you have to guide you through
life
no people dream of riches and they dream
of luxury and all of that but that's a
any defense against the harsh realities
of the world you have your character and
so what you do when you go to university
is you learn to say what you think as
clearly as you can and to take the
slings and arrows that come along with
that
not in an arrogant matter right because
like what the hell do you know you know
so you've got plenty to learn but you
want to formulate your thoughts
carefully you want to write what you
think
well why because when you're writing
your thinking you're laying out the
arguments that you're going to use to
structure your existence in the world
throughout your entire life and if you
start to twist and Bend those four
expedient reasons you're gonna warp your
soul and I mean I could talk about that
neurophysiological II if you want to you
know you become what you practice you
automate what you
Octus so if you automate expedience
speech for the sake of short-term gain
then that's what you're gonna produce
you're gonna produce expedient speech
for short-term gain well god help you if
you do that like there is nothing that
you will possibly do in your entire life
that will serve you better
than to get control of your voice in
university I let me see you do that by
reading right you read great people you
do that by writing what you think you
stay true to yourself while you write
what you think and you take the risks
and you gain the benefits that go along
with that you learn to stand up and
speak and to listen carefully and that
makes you a negotiator of unparalleled
power and if you're a negotiator of
unparalleled power there's nothing in
the world that won't open itself up to
you so that's what you're doing in
university and if you find professors
who who reject that and there's fewer of
them than you might think then it's your
sacred obligation to stand up for
yourself against that because it's gonna
happen to you throughout your whole life
and you might as well start practicing
how to do it right now so that's how it
looks to me yeah there's an old saying
that I I write
[Music]
I write in order to know what I think
and you'll note how compelled speech
interferes in that process yes
so it idea that you have to write what
your professor wants is the form of
compelled speech it's like it I really
do believe that this is a fundamental
issue as a therapist say when I'm trying
to help someone set their life straight
I do my best not to compel their speech
and the reason for that is quite clear
it's like you have your destiny with all
its attendant triumphs as' and
sufferings and it's on your shoulders I
don't want to tell you how to think I
don't want to tell you how to think
because I do not know how you should
think you have to figure that out for
yourself and and then you have to bear
the responsibility for that and you
you're a terribly arrogant fool if you
dare to tell someone else how it is that
they should conduct themselves through
life now I mean having said that well
obviously I say well you should tell the
truth or at least you should lie but
that's not a dictate of prov of actions
so to speak it's a dictate of process
it's like well you can't you shouldn't
interfere with the mechanism that allows
you to solve all the problems that you
will face in your life and you come to
University maybe to prepare for a trip
for a profession you know and to set
yourself up economically but to set
yourself economic up economically
properly I don't care what your
profession is going to be there is no
one who is more powerful than someone
who can communicate it doesn't matter
what the field it doesn't matter if
you're a plumber or a politician if you
can formulate your thoughts clearly if
you can conduct yourself honorably in
your action and your speech if you're
articulate and careful then the the
world opens itself up to you you have an
unlimited horizon of possibility so
[Applause]